foreign
[Music]
congratulations I was just telling you I
saw this originally in a can you know
when it was just debuting when you you
were just going with it it was amazing
then I saw it again uh here uh it's
plain interestingly I guess everywhere
around the world you know when you see
this with audiences and here this is
your first English language film so
what's it like playing here in in
Hollywood no it's great of course I'm in
uh this is the first time I'm back in La
since uh the square was nominated for
best foreign language film and uh thank
you for the square yeah but it was it
was really pleasant experience then and
it's so great to come back and
experience the audience culture you have
here in the US if you compare that with
the audience culture that is in in
Scandinavia like people are more lean
back and sitting like this and being
very critical and here you understand
that participating is a way of creating
a great show and I I think that is
something that I'm I'm actually trying
to encourage the Distributors and the
cinema owners in Sweden that we have to
try to adapt and try to create that kind
of audience culture in Sweden also yeah
yeah it's so it's so great to see your
stuff from Force Major to the square to
this of course you did a lot before that
too but all of it has a certain thread
to it you love dealing with human
behavior in in in all of these films
that seems to be a theme that you're
you're you're in love with here yeah I
guess I think
dilemmas is very uh efficient way of
trying to uh point out the things about
our behavior and if you if you break
down what a dilemma is I mean a dilemma
is when you the characters have two or
more options but none of the options are
easy and and all of the options are
going to have consequences and it's
basically a little bit like sociology I
I really I'm a fan of Sociology because
sociology is putting a spotlight on the
context of a situation rather than
pointing fingers towards the individual
and putting blame on the individual so
uh with sociology we can have an
understanding for why our behavior is in
the way we we Act and why we sometimes
tend to do things that we are not very
proud of and it it just a certain way of
giving knowledge about our behavior that
I love the approach of sociology what
what sparked this one I know like the
the square was set in the world of Art
and and museums and things and uh
Felicia uh it gets a ski resort and this
one here in fashion was there a
particular thing in your head that you
wanted to sort of like get into the
world of fashion here male model female
models all of that well the reason that
I uh wanted to do something in the
Fashion World from the beginning was
because when I met my wife
um eight years ago I was actually here
in La uh she is working as a fashion
photographer so I got very curious about
her profession I wanted to hear
everything about her profession and she
told me very interesting details about
for example how uh the different fashion
brands or marketing themselves the
strategies they have like the h m and
Balenciaga and how you can tell that the
hmm models are more often smiling and
then the more the expensive the brand
gets that's smile disappears from the
face of the models and it's almost like
when you look at the most expensive
brands that they are looking down on the
consumer and I thought it said something
about like how we position ourselves
with the clothes that we are buying uh
so it's really like we're looking on a
scale of a hierarchy and and looking at
the the group that we are connected to
and trying to find a camouflage so we
can fit into to the right group
and then I also got very interested in
she told me about the models and
uh for example that the male model
earning like one-third or one-fourth of
the of the female models and quite many
of the models are coming from working
class and I thought it was an
interesting aspect that beauty can
become a currency where you can climbing
class Society
and uh one story that was about a friend
of my wife when he was 19 years old he
was working as a car mechanic and he got
Street costed in in Hamburg Hamburg is
to sit in in Germany where the uh where
the fashion industry is located
and he got Street coastered and look at
the question you want to work as a model
and it's like yeah sure I can try that
and two years later he's one of the best
paid male models in the industry and
you know all of a sudden he had gotten
used to a certain kind of lifestyle that
he couldn't have access to where he came
from or the kind of profession he had
before
and when he is up there on the top he
does a perfume campaign that if I would
show it to you you would probably
recognize this guy because it became
very famous those images it was Peter
Lindbergh that did that campaign but
when he's up there on the top he
realized oh my God I'm starting to lose
lose my hair
so he's losing his currency and you know
the drop to go back to start to work as
a car mechanic again it's kind of
painful to do
so he went to his agent and he talked to
his agent and he didn't look at his hair
issue and he said okay maybe you have
two more years working working as a
model but we also have another problem
then not only the hair the other thing
is that you're so connected to this
perfume brand that made you famous so in
order to make you get jobs on the same
level we need to Rebrand you
and
and my my suggestion in order to Rebrand
you is that you get together with a
famous girlfriend
and this guy he was a little bit of a
romantic guy you know but I want to be
in love you know and
um uh so for me it was a complete new
thing this with the Branded couple uh
context and I was a little bit
fascinated because I was pitching this
film and the idea about the film okay we
have Carl and Jay and they are a branded
couple and when I pitch it to people in
my generation and then older people uh
I'm born in the 70s then uh the people
that are pitched it too they were like
oh my God but how how horrible a branded
couple but what about love
and then when I was pitching it to
people I was born like Millennials and I
said yeah and then we have calling
yayanda or a branded couple they just go
uh-huh okay
they did it was a complete different
attitude change to that so I felt that
there's something about our times in
this digital era uh when we're
positioning ourselves uh in social media
and so on that have changed a certain
how do you say look we have on love and
and relationships you have so much in
you know I look at this movie as in
three acts essentially you know you have
that whole thing with the models and and
the social influencing and I have to say
Harris Dickinson and the late great
Charlie uh was just fantastic uh in that
and um
particularly in a scene the dinner scene
where it becomes this very beautifully
played argument about whose pain and did
that come out of a real experience for
you or something I oh yeah I have to yes
I have to admit it does the thing that
also happened to me and my wife in the
in the early stage of our relationship
and it was interesting because I I come
like from the Scandinavian background I
was brought up by my mother and she
always taught me you know you have to be
equal a relationship have to be equal
otherwise you will not be happy and my
wife comes from Germany and she comes
from a more patriotic structure family
structure and um uh in the beginning I
want to impress her you know so it's I
mean I mean a little bit of a 200 as the
man so I'm paying for the first you know
the third second in there the third
inner but all of a sudden I feel I like
her too much uh to keep on playing this
role because it's not going to be
impossible too much to keep pain for her
exactly yeah
and I feel like okay I have to grab the
bull by the horn and bring this up
because I felt it was a sensitive topic
and then she says to me okay uh when I
paid the 13 she says thank you so much
tomorrow I will invite you
and we were like on a vacation when this
happened so then but the next day when
we were sitting there at the restaurant
I'm starting to get nervous when it gets
closer for the bill to come on the table
and when the bill comes on the table she
doesn't do like Yaya did in this shot
you know like that she's taking up the
makeup mirror and like happens to it
pretends that he doesn't see that the
bill comes on the table but if the bill
is like put on the table and she doesn't
pick it up
and then the time aspect is much more
painful for a man I think all men can
agree on that right so after a while I
can't stand it so just lean forward a
little bit and immediately she says
thank you honey that's so sweet of you
and I see my male ego you know like the
person like I I I'm completely like uh
feeling uh how do you say yeah I I I
don't feel like paying the bill but at
the same time my male Eagle is taking up
the wallet and putting the car there and
I'm trying to pretend like nothing have
happened I'm just like please don't ask
me how I feel now don't ask me what's up
with me and when she's asking so what's
up what's up with you I'm like okay you
know and finally I don't have any choice
but bringing it up and it becomes like a
roller coaster of a fight where you can
tell it's gender expectations it's the
role of the man and role of the woman
it's the the kind of exchange of money
towards like Beauty all the topics that
I was basically dealing with in this
film
um uh was in that single situation so
when I was writing the script I just
felt like
I I had to I have to use it I have to
put it in the film and but it was also
kind of beautiful moment because it
happens exactly like it does in the film
you know we we go in there we walk home
actually we didn't go in a car but when
we go up in the elevator uh the the same
thing happens you know yeah I I try to
bring it up in a nice way but I don't
manage to and uh and it it it goes to
the point when she pushes down a 50 Euro
bill in my shirt pocket and I freak out
you know uh and I feel completely
castrated and I actually pushed the
50-year bill in into the like in between
the elevator and the wall so it was down
in the Elevator Shaft
wow and then I walk away and I said like
okay I did the right thing I stood up
for myself you know but the corridor is
quite long so I have time to regret
myself before I reach the room
and then I'm in the room and it's like
where is she like texting and uh and and
finally when she comes back we actually
have a talk about these things that is
on a level you know that can happen
early in the relationship when you don't
have any filters when you don't try to
play in a role anymore and it's not 100
sure that you're going to be together so
you actually uh you dare to be
completely honest
and it didn't play out it was not the
same kind of topics that it was for
calling Yaya but but it was also
something that brought us closer and and
the day after we could laugh laugh about
it a painful laugh but we could laugh
about it I didn't know when I asked that
it was a documentary you were shooting
there uh that's pretty amazing you know
there's so many scenes in this uh you
know when you get to the yacht which I
understand is the actual Onassis yacht
that was owned by Onassis the Christina
or something
um you shot on that yacht and uh and had
this incredible storm seasick scene
that's wild humor hilarious and
everything that goes on and then some of
them wind up on a desert island so
structurally when you're writing a
script like that did you see the movie
going in that direction or did you have
one thing in mind like the desert island
or something no I definitely knew that I
wanted to have it in a three-part
structure and I I I knew that I wanted
to look on hierarchies on the currency
of Beauty First in the fashion world and
then on the luxury yacht and then I was
very interested in to to put this
character or some of the characters on a
deserted island and like take away all
the old hierarchies and look at like
privileged modern human beings that
basically don't have any practical
knowledgeable about about surviving and
and then of course
to turn around the hierarchies and and
put dolly De Leon's character Abigail in
the in the top of the hierarchy and and
look at the power structure what happens
when you end up in the top of the
hierarchy because I understand also you
know like I fish and I I have a lot of
responsibility for this group shouldn't
that give me some kind of Advantage you
know and there's a lot of things that
comes with
power and how to say the abuse of power
or the use of power that I think that
you can create a certain kind of
understanding that like if you have a
very very strong hierarchy and you are
in the top of a structure then then how
us humans start like basically start to
abuse our power and I didn't want it to
something that an explanation model that
it's about the sex that is doing it like
the demand men are doing it more than
women I wanted to raise the question is
it maybe the structure in itself that it
creates this behavior and but and Carl's
sleeping with her to get an advantage on
getting pretzels and things yes exactly
and I I was in love when I was writing
the script I was in love with this line
I love you you give me fish I thought it
was uh and it's very often like that
when I'm working with the script you
know I fall in love with some lines and
I'm just I can't wait to get to that
moment when I get to direct this season
and can I make them say it is in a
believable way and yeah this is your
first English language film but the
casting it's truly International these
wonderful actors here I'm wondering in
putting the cast together Dolly DeLeon
as Abigail is just fantastic in this
movie she really is
but they're all great the the actor that
plays Dimitri is fantastic in this and
then you get Woody Harrelson who's very
well known here
um across the board uh this kind of
casting how difficult it is to put the
kind of cast you envision here together
well okay I want to be humble but you
know when when I set the goals with
working on a film I always try to how do
you say explain what we're aiming for
for example when I was talking to the
casting director I said I want to create
the Real Madrid
Ensemble so like really okay we are
going to take the best actors from
different parts of the world and create
an ensemble that is working really well
together that is dynamic that that is
fun to look at and that brings in entity
in the right way and so on a colorful
palette basically and um
we we were in the Philippines in Manila
we were in in Europe in all the big
towns in Europe and we were in New York
and L.A and
um yeah and what I'd like to do when I'm
doing costing because I'm also
participating in the course thing that
is that I played a different characters
and do improvisations with actors and
costing sessions that it's quite long
often so I don't want to put any
pressure on the actor I want them to
dare to do mistakes dare to to take
risks and trying to figure out okay what
happens if this guy is going to play
this character and so often it comes
like ideas when you try out different
actors if they if they just dare to like
lean back in and and and make sure that
they are there with themselves like for
example when we're working with slapco
burik that plays Dimitri from the
beginning I was thinking that I should
have a much more tough a Russian
oligarch that was uh
like in a completely different way than
he played played it and when he played
it you just played it like a warm
warm-hearted figure that was very Frank
about his background and uh uh
um in a very hard to say give give a lot
of energy to to me when I was when I was
working with him so that that took me in
a different direction than I thought
from the beginning so I tried to be open
and try to be really see every single
actor that we are trying out
a very unique director when I saw this
movie I walked out I told somebody God I
wish Billy Wilder was alive to see this
movie
because he would have loved it you know
it reminded me of those greats I'm
wondering you know the satire everything
the tone to keep the tone of this is
like a whole half hour discussion right
there but did you have any film
Inspirations going into this I mean
people that you looked up to and I said
you know this is missing and I want to
do this kind of kind of film
um
um there was one critics that wrote when
they saw the square that I was a mixture
between Michael hanika and Larry David
and I and I was very that I felt like
I'm proud when when he's writing this
and
um
you know when I was doing uh already
when I was doing Forrest major I had a
feeling of there's a possibility to
combine the best part of the American
tradition in filmmaking because you have
such a great connection with the
audience and the European uh tradition
of filmmaking we have a problem with one
thing and it is because like we are
state founded and when we are state
founded when we get the money as a
production company uh we are already
economically safe so uh the downside of
that is that we don't punch as hard in
order to reach the audience so I had a
feeling when I was starting to make
Forest mayor that
um uh the European Cinema have lost
connection with the audience and I
looked back on on filmmakers like bunuel
for example there was like wild and
entertaining and at the same time they
was trying to provoke questions and
raise questions
and uh so I wouldn't like to try to get
closer I felt myself that I was much
more of like an art house genre
filmmaker almost and I wanted to move
closer to to Be Free as a film director
I wanted to not have aesthetically like
formalistic Dogma that I was
leaning back on and uh
so when I did Force mayor I really
wanted to combine this uh these two
traditions and get closer to what I felt
at some Wilder filmmaking that I that I
could get inspiration from from the 70s
and I have to tell you about an
experience that I had at that time it
was a friend of mine he he was on the
flight between it's not between Venice
but you know after Venice Film Festival
then the whole industry is going to
Toronto Film Festival and he he was on
the flight with the whole like his
colleagues and so on and uh a lot of
European uh people from the industry and
he was a little curious what are they
looking on on the screens when they're
flying over the Atlantic and he saw that
we are basically not watching our own
films everybody was watching Adam
Sandler and then Adam Sandler is great
it's nothing about that but but I I
thought it was symptomatic that we are
not watching our own films so I wanted
to have an approach that we're creating
a certain kind of uh Cinema that is
making a wild entertaining roller
coaster ride at the same time like we
are like that we want to click on it
actually and that we uh at the same time
we are raising questions and so on
well I have to say you succeeded Beyond
anybody's Wildest Dreams here two Palm
doors so far in your career and much
Acclaim uh thank you for coming out here
to film independent thanks for joining
us I have to let him go because he's got
to be somewhere else but I know he
wanted to talk to you guys thank you
guys for coming out today too thank you
so much thank you
[Music]